[Music]
hi I'm Christopher Heine in this video
series we're talking about high falls in
ki Chi ten what are they so the first
one we talked about the spilling
dispelling the myths of okie Chi 10 and
why them there might not be what you
think they are then we talked about how
to do your first floating roll or a high
fall and now we're going to talk about
some refinements so how do you get the
best high fall you possibly can
I'm gonna call Josh out here and we're
gonna go to work for you guys Josh okay
so some tips on improving your high fall
so once you can do a basic hypothesis
that's the starter high fall then
there's a whole progression of high
falls they're really hard to high falls
like a shy Onaga is generally a pretty
hard high fall sometimes eating you know
gates can be hard eyeballs there are
easier hikes oom you know toch is a easy
a high fall Kota guy she's a pretty easy
high fall and Chloe nage once you learn
to relax is a pretty easy - one of the
most important things to understand is
that you need to keep your arms in front
of your center when you're high calling
so for example I was gonna throw Josh in
a sumio post here as I start to move it
I'm just gonna go through a couple
actions Joshua actually high fall as I
move Josh should let his whole body move
with his Center so notice as I'm moving
his arm his whole body is tracking that
and that means he's staying together and
tight and that's gonna make that
revolution real easy and Josh lets his
arm get away from the center and it's
gonna be real hard for him to - he's
gonna stagnate and not want a high fall
maybe get caught in his shoulder and
that kind of sucks like so all kinds of
bad stuff will happen so it's no good if
he gets too excited about going early
he's likely to just kind of let his butt
kind of fall out or try and kick over in
some weird way but the timings not gonna
work out right so all he wants to do is
really focus on keeping his Center his
hand so as I throw high Josh and
assuming a punch I fall
notice how he keeps his arm with the
center okay so as he comes over just
keeps his arm and his Center together
really really nice
so that way he states together as one
piece that makes the rotation really
easy now the same thing to be true with
Nakota guys so we're here in a quote a
guy and enough apply this quote of guys
just let's keep the whole box boom and
he turns over now understand again that
this is worth reiterating that's not
because I'm so powerful that I throw him
with my ferocious force it's because his
wrist is getting twisted really hard
he's got no easy way to land and so he
lets his whole body come over so josh is
choosing to let his body come over in
that right the same would be true of a
Shiho nage my fault right so if I'm here
as I go to school body right around that
point right so josh is isolating that
point now she or not gets kind of hard
because you got to do it from a high
position right so all jobs just trained
to do is keep his body centered together
right as that's going on now a Koshi
nage seems like it's a hard hight ball
but it's actually a really really easy
Highfill so if i had Josh set up here in
a kochi nugget what Josh first wants to
do is reach his arm over here and see if
he can get a hold of me now he could
grab my D like this or he could wrap my
shoulder like this either one but he
wants to keep himself tight now what
he's doing by doing that is keeping his
Center and his arm law so when I go to
throw him it's really really easy for
him to let himself fall right over
because he's wrapping around with his
arm and locking on to me I'm stable so
when he gets thrown his whole core can
just rotate right around that point so
whenever you're taking a high fall if
you're having a problem with it they're
getting kind of my grandma would say
Annie Goblin right which is things all
over the place right if it's getting
like that
then it's probably because your arms not
staying with your Center anymore you
want to keep your arms right in front of
your Center and then let your whole body
turn right around that arm this will
make your - I sand clean you get those
real pretty hakama flowing through the
air kind of high Falls which is what
everybody wants to be able to take an
idea I'm Chris Ryan thanks for watching
[Music]